hello everyone and welcome to today's
webinar
fast and reliable gene synthesis for
optimized protein expression
i am jennifer woods of labrutz and i'll
be your moderator for today's event
today's educational web seminar is
presented by labrus
and brought to you by thermo fisher
scientific
to learn more visit thermofisher.com
let's get started before we begin i'd
like to remind everyone that this event
is
interactive we encourage you to
participate by submitting as many
questions as you want
at any time you want during the
presentation to do so
simply type them into the ask a question
box and click send
we'll answer as many questions as we
have time for at the end of the
presentation
if you have trouble seeing or hearing
the presentation
click on the support tab found at the
top right of the presentation window
or report your problem by clicking on
the ask a question box
located on the far left of your screen
this presentation is educational and
thus offers continuing education credits
please click on the continuing education
credits tab
located at the top right of the
presentation window and follow the
process
to obtain your credits i now present
today's speaker
claudia keokini staff scientist in r
d at thermo fisher scientific for a
complete biography
on our speaker please visit the
biography tab at the top of your screen
claudia you may now begin your
presentation
good morning and good afternoon to all
attendees and thank you for taking the
time to join this webinar today
and before i start with a presentation
i'd like to mention what is the mission
of thermo fisher scientific which is to
enable our customers to make the world
healthier cleaner and safer
and this is the mission we are
particularly proud of today
in these difficult times of a global
pandemic
in which thermo fisher is helping by
developing
accurate diagnostic tools and supporting
our customers in developing
new therapeutical approaches and
hopefully very soon
new effective accents against copied 19.
for example from gene art thermofisher
we've been sending along this year's
thousands of gene for designated for
vaccine development
okay here is the agenda for today's
webinar i will start
introducing gene synthesis how it works
and how it can facilitate your discovery
workflow
i will then explain what gene
optimization is and why
it is key for a successful gene
expression
and ultimately for increasing protein
production
i will describe how to effectively join
biosynthetic dna
pieces to build larger constructs and in
particular
we will take a look at experimental
datas obtained
when combining strings dna fragments and
gnard gibson assembly technology
in the second part of the webinar i will
focus on protein production
especially on how to boost protein
production by using
advanced tools already available for you
in the market
and combining it with our expertise in
producing protein
and finally we will see how to go from
digital sequence to purified protein
using our gene to protein service which
gives you access
to your desired protein in the amount
and quality you need
so you can save time and concentrate on
your actual research
synthetic biology is very powerful and
is
connected to many other disciplines it
supports basic research but also
industrial research
for example through acceleration of drug
discovery
it is key for new therapeutic approaches
like
cell therapy or gene therapy for the
production of new antibody for example
for
fight against cancer of course it is
possible through synthetic biology to
develop new biotechnologies
and it is also the base for personalized
medicine approaches
where based on the knowledge of the dna
of the patients
you can basically find
new tailored solutions for
for many diseases and hopefully
as we will see very soon for covet 19
synthetic biology also enables to
develop
safe new vaccines and of course you can
think of synthetic biology
as something which goes beyond life
science
one example might be data storage in dna
so the real power of synthetic biology
is that it really gives you access
to any gene and any protein you want
regardless the origin
and complexity of these and it doesn't
matter for which purpose you need a
protein
maybe you need a single protein to study
structure or function
or you are in the middle of the
screening process where you're searching
for the right candidates
in all these approaches you can start
and
design proteins from scratch and all you
need is an electronic sequence
so you can have access to this
entire workflow just starting with an
amino acid sequence or dna sequence
and what it comes next is that the
sequence is
optimized and i will talk more
extensively about gene optimization
after gene optimization then we can
really form
a physical dna template and this is the
gene synthesis step
and what normally happens next is that
the gene of interest can be subcloned
into a vector
and used for your own application to
produce plasmid
or it can use as a master gene to
produce gene variants
of course we are also able to produce
entire gene libraries
and what happens next with plasma
preparation normally researchers do a
transformation of e coli
or they transfect cell lines mammalian
cells for protein production so
this is just an example of what your
discovery workflow might look like and
what i want to really focus on today
are three aspects gene optimization gene
synthesis
and protein expression from mammalian
cells
you can think of this workflow like
something we can support you with
and you can either outsource the entire
workflow
or just ask us to support you in
taking over part of this workflow to
accelerate your research
here thermo fisher we are considered
experts in writing dna
and we write in dna i mean really
synthesizing dna from scratch
in this process it is crucial to adapt
the dna
to your heart's organism when we talk
about heterologous gene expression
everyone understands the importance of
the current usage
since the genetic code is yes universal
but
it is degenerated so that amino acid can
be coded by
different cartons and we know that the
frequency with which
connots are picked is different from in
each and every organism and this
correlates
with the amount of transfer rna present
in the cell
so it is understandable that current
usage
influences in the first place the
efficiency of the translation
and process but there are other factors
which really play a very important role
and these are connected to the
structural property
of the rna i think of gc content
or the presence of crypto supply sides
direct repeats
rna secondary structures and any element
causing instability of the sequence so
all these factors
play really a rule and can hamper
protein expression so the gene optimizer
technology was developed at gen art by
our lte team
and this takes into consideration 20
different parameters to optimize dna
for especially mammalian cells and just
to
make you clear that this is a very
complex process
you can take a look at this this is an
hypothetical dna sequence so your wild
type chain
on the left side of this slide
and this wild type sequence might
contain unfavorable cottons which are
underlined in red
and more favorable columns which are
underlined in green
and now if you imagine to replace all
the red colors by the green columns
this would be a quite easy process but
this is a simple
back translation so you don't need
really a complicated algorithm to do
this operation
and this would not reach the goal which
is to really optimize your gene for
expression
in your heart so the goal is to find a
trade-off between
the cotton usage and the presence in
this case the absence
of those unwanted motives which i was
listing before and this is what
gene optimizer technology is doing and
what this algorithm does is that it
considers
all possible carbon combination but not
in the entire gene sequence
but it takes a small window of 10 to 20
amino acids
and in this small window it checks all
possible carbon combinations according
to the current adaptation
index and what happens is that when the
first optimal current is found
this is locked down and the window
slides from
five prime to three prime and the
process is repeated over and over
a second window is also considered to
evaluate the current combination
and as i was mentioning before
gene optimizer really pays attention
that these unwanted motives are not
introduced so that protein expression is
not hampered
so this is more or less the principle
with which our technology
works and but i have also just to say
that gene optimizer algorithm works
two-fold
so on the one hand we have the
optimization
for maximal protein expression and on
the other hand
we want to minimize the complexity of
the dna sequence which is fundamental to
have a successful
gene assembly and we need to minimize
also the effort for us as a manufacturer
so
and to increase of course the
probability that your sequence is
immediately 100 correct
so the next step after gene optimization
is
to break up the gene sequence into
oligonucleotides
and this is not a trivial process so we
speak here about intelligent oligodesign
and the oligos are of course partially
overlapping
and they are designed in a way that they
hybridize to one another and they go
together only in the right order
what you see here is a picture of our
manufacturing
department and of course we synthesize
oligos in large scale but we've been
optimizing a process over the past years
to
reduce the scale and to really be able
to synthesize oligo of great quality
with a high throughput process enabling
us now to synthesize over 30 000 oligos
per runs third day
so what happened next after
oligosynthesis is that the oligos are
assembled
in a gene assembly reaction and this is
kind of similar to pcr
from the three prime oh the dna is
expanded
and the process is done iteratively so
that the full length
gene is formed and this is then inserted
into our standard production vector or a
customer vector if possible
and what happens next is that the
plasmid is then
transferred into cells into bacterial
cells
by transformation this is fundamental
not only to get
enough plasmid dna of course we need
them to analyze
single colonies to screen them and then
grow bacteria culture
but it's also fundamental to isolate
single plasmid
and make possible that your plasmid
preparation is monoclonal
so after cognitive screening
a plasmid preparation is done and the
plasmid is analyzed
by next generation sequencing also here
we are really increasing our sequencing
capacity over the past year
so that now we are able to do 29 000
reads per day
and after we make sure that the sequence
is 100 correct the dna is tried
packaged and then sent to the customer
along with final documentation
normally using standard gene synthesis
um you can really quickly have access to
your dna
and you can also request an additional
sub cloning step
so that we transfer your dna or gene of
interest
into for example an expression vector so
if you go for the standard true
synthesis
you can pick one of the over 115 liter
transpression vectors
and this service is available
in just a few days but if you're
interested in really
fast cloning then you you or you can
order our express cloning
and in this case you can have access to
one of the nine
in-vitrogen expression vectors listed
here and in some cases for some eligible
customer we are able to take your vector
re-adapt re-adapted to our manufacturing
strategy and then
do directly the cloning experiment into
your
wish vector you will now see
a polling question appear on your screen
your participation is greatly
appreciated
all right so what i also wanted to
mention is
this standard gene synthesis service
will give you access to a few micrograms
of dna there's normally five micrograms
of dna which are delivered
to to the user but we can increase this
quantity and scale up
to 20 milligram you can choose different
vector
different vectors of course as i was
saying but you can also choose different
buffers to do
the plasmid preparation like trees water
or pbs
and of course you have the option to
choose between tubes and plates
and we have additional services like
film finish service where we can
allocate the dna in a small aliquot
labeled
for your direct use other options
are to order tse-free production or a
low level of endotoxin this is crucial
to many researchers doing
as a downstream application transfection
of mammalian cells
so um we talked all about gene synthesis
now
and gene synthesis is of course um the
most
easy way i would say to get access to
your dna because
you you don't need to do any step in the
lab
but there is also another option that is
really very
used by uh researchers especially in uh
in the academia and this is
the option to order strings dna
fragments
strings dna fragments are
double-stranded dna
they are done exactly using the same
mechanism as for gene synthesis so it
starts with a bioinformatics step
gene optimization oligosynthesis and
assembly
and the only difference is that the
cloning step is skipped
so what we normally do is the bulk
sequencing
of this synthetic dna like sequencing of
a pcr
product and then measuring of the dna
concentration
and then just dry the dna and send it
along with the final documentation
so meaning that there is no downstream
service
normally this um we deliver at least 200
nanograms of dna
but the quantity average quantity which
we ship this 900 nanograms
and this service is doable for dna
in a length comprised between 150 base
pairs and 3
000 base pairs so the practical thing of
string is that they
are not only convenient but they come
really fast
in as few as three business days for the
uh the easy and short version and
what you have to do is if you want to
have access to your clone is just you
need to take strings
clone it in the vector of interest and
then do the screening process to pick
carney do the screening and sequencing
so this is what uh make the product a
bit cheaper
compared to gene synthesis but it's
still a great quality
okay so i think we have a second
round of questions here you will now see
a polling question appear on your screen
your participation is greatly
appreciated
all right so general strings are really
a convenient solution to get access to
your synthetic
dna and we know that many researchers
are used to
order genome strings even if they need
something larger so what they do is they
combine
general strings together into a larger
construct and
if you're interested in doing that i
strongly recommend to use
gener gibson assembly and i mean there
are many
many tools that thermo fisher makes
available to you
to clone dna examples which are very
well known
in any lab are topo cloning gateway
cloning
these are very efficient systems and
they are ideal
in case of i would say a single fragment
but when it comes to assembly of many
fragments
it really makes sense to look at a
technology
um which is efficient fast and
and enables you to really clone
these pieces totally scarless and
or as we can say seamlessly and this is
the reason why general
gibson assembly is the perfect solution
in this case
and what i want to highlight next is
that
okay gibson is method which is um really
out there
since long time and the beauty of this
system is that you don't need
any additional restriction size to add
to your insert
all what you what you need to do is make
sure that you have
small homologous region the short
regions are between 20 and 40 base pairs
in common two fragments you want to join
and in this picture the somology region
are highlighted in
colors and
only by using those homology region in
your fragments
and the gibson assembly kit you get
final product
where you have absolutely no scars
and equivalency bound molecule
so the last last year
we would been developing kids here at
june ginart thermo fisher and the
principle
is exactly the same principle as in any
gibson assembly technology
so the mix contains a cocktail of
enzymes
working contemporary so we have an
exonuclease chewing back homologous ends
a dna polymerase filling the gaps
starting
from the free oah free and then a dna
like this which seals the dna mix
and the beauty of this is that your
final product is totally covalently
bound and it is suitable to be
transformed
into heat component cells but also into
electrocomponent cells
and this is something which is really
important when you build
large dna since electroporation is much
more efficient
compared to heat shock
so the two options we can offer are
general gibson assembly hi-fi
kit and the ex kit hi-fi i would say is
the perfect solution for
assembly of up to six fragments
it's a single step reaction is a
isothermical reaction
and it really gives very high
performance high cloning efficiency
and it also has an interesting
application which i will go through in
one minute
and regarding the ex kit this is the
most
robust kit and it's a two-step format
and it's suitable not only for simple
cloning experiments but also for
cloning of up to 15 fragments and it
also delivers a very high cloning
efficiency
up to 95 so both
are available as a single master mix or
combined with competent cells
as a kit and in the next couple of
slides i want to show you the results we
got
by using those kits in our lab to join
dna fragments
and in this experiment for example we've
been using
two kb inserts and we could join four
pieces
into pc dna 3.4 vector those dna
segments will share an entomology region
of about 30 base pairs
and what we did after transformation of
electrocomponent cells we picked
colonies
and then analyzed them by carne pcr
where we
detected the transition region between
first and second fragments
which is here on the gel and third and
fourth fragment again
here analyzed on a giant phrases and
what we calculated is the cloning
efficiency
as the number of colonies carrying the
full length
so both pcr combination over
the number of colonies which we analyzed
we did three independent experiments
and as you see here only in the first
experiment we got 100 cloning efficiency
and in three separate experiments we got
an average chronic efficiency of 96
so i think this is really good result
for an 8kb fragment
hi-fi kit is really interesting because
it can be used
also to join fragments which originally
do not share
any homologous regions and this can be
really interesting
in many cases for example if you you
want
to have access to a fragment which is
tricky to amplify by pcr because it's
complex or too large
you can just cut it and then make it
compatible to your vector
using stitching oligonucleotides so
using
basically single strand dna functioning
as a bridge
between your wanted fragment and the
target vector
and you can use this technology even to
assemble pieces
so in this example we joined two
fragments which were not share nemology
um with three different oligonucleotides
working as a bridge
another example can be if you need
to introduce the same general strings
which you ordered
into different vectors so you don't need
to reorder strings every time you change
vector
you can even shuffle fragment with this
technique and so on
and since we weren't 100 sure that we
are picking the right oligo
concentration we tried this experiment
in a pretty bright range
of oligoconcentration and as you can see
we got the optimal cloning efficiency
using
30 to 45 nanomolar of oligos
but we still obtain a decent result
even using much less and much more
articles meaning that
the technology is really very robust
um in the next two slides i'd like to
take a
look at the performance of the ex kit
this is
the one which we absolutely recommend
when you're joining many pieces together
in this experiment we were joining 0.5
kb
dna fragments or strings and
we were comparing the performance of the
gibson assembly
with our own ginar seamless cloning kit
as you can see in this picture
where we were using top 10 heat
component cells
both kit were doing very good with six
fragments
but the performance of the general
seamless cloning is going down when we
pick
eight and ten fragments on the other
hand the general gibson assembly ex is
very stable
really providing high cloning efficiency
even with 10 pieces
and when we used teleporation we got
even higher cloning efficiency
up to even 90 percent with 10 fragments
which was kind of expected since
as i mentioned before electroporation is
the
really the method of choice when you're
doing more complex experiments
and here of course we were not comparing
with the general seamless cloning kit
since in this case this kit is not
suitable
with uh to to be used
without preparation so
with this i like to um
quickly wrap up what we said about
the gibson technology so the combination
in our strings dna fragments engineer
gibson technology is a very convenient
and fast way to build large construct
you have full design flexibility because
you can pick any vector you want and
this is
a clear advantage compared to other
techniques like topo cloning
or gateway cloning where you are
restricted to reuse
other vectors which are linked to those
kits
so you have also full design flexibility
you can join multiple fragments
and many small fragments or even a few
large fragments
so you can define the experimentary the
way you want
and of course you have access to the
general optimization technology so you
can optimize
the sequence or of your gnr strings in
in a way that they're perfect for
expression
in your final heterological exhaust and
if you are interested in those kits and
you want to
understand more about how to set up the
reaction and all about the tips and
tricks
i recommend you to take a look at white
papers at the thermofisher.com gibson
assembly page
i think we have again pulling here
you will now see a polling question
appear on your screen
your participation is greatly
appreciated
now i'd like to move to the second part
of the webinar which is about
writing proteins and with this i mean
synthesizing protein denovo
starting from an amino acid sequence
so like in case of the gene synthesis
workflow
which we were looking at before also in
case of the protein workflow you can
decide whether to take advantage of our
expertise
in protein manufacturing and let us
perform the entire process
or if you prefer just can you can let us
take over
only parts of this workflow so the the
tedious or time-consuming parts
so here at thermo-fischer gene art we
have the expertise in doing protein
synthesis
in eukaryotic cells and in particular in
mammalian cells
and insect cells
and the reason for this is that even
though we know that
many scientists are still used equal at
least still using e coli for protein
expression
since e coli is cheap and fast growing
and its genetic is perfectly
characterized
we also know that there are several
drawbacks in using e coli
when expressing proteins of eukaryotic
origin
and the reasons are that in e coli is
not possible to make post-translational
modifications
such as phosphorylation or o and n
glycosylation
for example m-glycosylation is
fundamental to produce
functional antibodies there are also
limitations in the size of the protein
that you can produce
and especially for membrane proteins for
example
the missing environment really do not
favor um the right expression of those
proteins
and also many other proteins do not fold
correctly
and they form inclusion bodies so that
the protein cannot
be redissolved and obtained in a
functional
in a functional way so for this reason
it is
preferable to express eukaryotic protein
in eukaryotic cells
and also i have to say many of our
customers of
biotech and pharma they do
research with mammalian cells for many
reasons
also for vaccine development human
therapy and diagnostics
so when we're talking about autologous
expressions the expression of mammalian
genes in mammalian cells one might ask
the question
why should we optimize the gene for
expression
and the reason is simple is that many
proteins are not
meant to be expressed at a high level in
the cells
since nature do not optimize protein for
maximal expression
but rather for optimal regulation
so another reason is of course that by
optimizing genes we can get rid of all
motives
that can hamper expression and reduce
at the end the yield of the protein so
examples can be premature
polyadenylation
presence of alternative splice inside
amarone destabilization
and any elements causing transcription
transcriptional silencing
so to prove the efficiency of our
mammalian gene optimization algorithm
our r d scientists did a few years ago
a study which was published selecting
50 proteins belonging to the most
studied protein classes
these were including protein kinases
transcriptional factors ribosomal
proteins cytokines
and membrane proteins each gene was
synthesized
in two versions so the y type and as an
optimized gene for expression in
mammalian cells
and after gene synthesis and cloning
hec293 cells were transfected in
triplicate
to minimize the variances
and then protein yield octane from
wiretype and from optimized gene
were just compared
and what you see in this picture here is
a western blot analysis
of the resulting proteins and the output
was very positive so in
86 percent of the cases the optimized
genes
over-performed the wild-type genes and
in 96
of the cases the optimized gene resulted
in at least
equal protein levels compared to the y
type
so it seems that gene optimization is is
really
an advantage and increases protein
expression
so what we did next is that we pressure
test it again
gene optimizer technology by comparing
it with
analog technologies offered by our
competitors
and for this purpose a selection of
protein kinases were
was taken also in this case optimized
genes
delivered more protein compared to the
white type and the best result we got
it was a 27 full increase on the
contrary in case of
competitor methods they failed at least
in one example
to provide better yields compared to the
y type
so in conclusion it seems so with
gene art gene optimization algorithm for
mammalian cells
we have a very good tool in our hands to
increase protein production
so in the next slide i want to i want to
show you
how to combine gene arch in optimization
with two other thermofisher tools
available for you in the market
to really boost protein expression
so i'm talking about gibco reagents and
culture media
and xp 293 and expitual cell lines
so the git commedia was developed to
enable cells to grow
at a three times higher density compared
to standard media
and xp293 and expedito are optimized to
grow
at high density and produce more protein
per cell
so just as an example xp293 can be
transfected
at a density of three million cells per
milliliter
and expitual at a density of 6 million
cells per milliliter
so those two products are available in a
kit
along with a highly efficient
transaction reagent
which reliably delivers your clone dna
into the cells so now it is
understandable that
the effect is even improved when the
when those
high performance systems are compared
are
combined with our generator gene
optimization method so basically
when we transfect the cells with
mammalian optimized cloned dna
and this provides a protein yield
increase of three
to ten fold all right so
using those tools it is very likely you
to obtain
the same results we would obtain in our
laboratory
when doing protein manufacturing however
there are many benefits in using our
gene to protein service
so the service has the advantage to
offer to you a full design
flexibility so you can select any of the
vector
present in our in our list on the home
page so more than 115 vitrogen vectors
or you can send us your own vector
established in your lab
you can choose among sp293 exp cho
mammalian system and also ff9
insect cells combined with the bachelor
virus suppression system
you can decide the scale of your
experiment the purification method
and of course you can request the
customized process analysis
so and what is really important to say
is that
everything comes from one hand so there
is no need to transfer
material or information from one side to
the other
because everything is done in house at
our site
so concerning um protein purification
and
and concerning the scale i would
just talk about it in a next two slides
so i want to concentrate now on analysis
and at the beginning when this service
was offered
we were able to provide you a standard
analysis such as sds page or western
blot and command sustaining
and of course the measurement of the
protein amount but now we are able to
to also fulfill other requests
so you can request capillary
electrophoresis to determine the degree
of purity of your protein
or hplc chromatography to determine the
monomeric state
of your antibody for example or even
mass spectrometry analysis to check the
efficiency
of the glycosylation for your antibodies
so there is
plenty of possibility to really
customize
this service concerning the cells as i
was saying before as
the choices between mammalian cells and
insect cells and but i have to say that
xp293 and expicho systems
they are the preferred system from the
researchers
ordering our gene department service
capacity is constantly growing so and in
terms of scale we are really very very
flexible
so last year there was a a new product
which was launched and this is the small
scale protein service
this is really suitable to customers
doing for for example high throughput
screening experiment
so researchers who do not need high
amounts of protein but they need many
proteins at once
so in this small scale service we offer
24 to 96
multi-wide expression of course there is
also the possibility to go up with the
scale
and have a suspension culture in 30
milliliter or 25 liter
and concerning capacity this is as i was
saying constantly increasing
so currently we can do 300 liter
suspension culture cell per week
and additionally 100 liter
in bioreactor culture
so and regarding protein purification as
i was saying before
this is also totally customizable so
adaptable to your
to your youth many researchers are
interested in antibodies
and i think that more than 80 percent of
the protein we purify daily are
antibodies
but of course we are able to produce
non-antibody proteins as well
so you can pick any of the affinity tags
normally used in the lab like
his tag strep tag flack or ctag
and the regarding purification
there's also the possibility to go for
different procedures
it can be customized using different
protocols which you normally
take in your lab different resins or
buffers but the standard process is to
start
with an affinity chromatography like
kind of enrichment step
then switch to ion exchange
chromatography
and then close with a size exclusion
chromatography which is the final
polishing step so this is just a
hypothetical way to purify your proteins
and of course there are also additional
options
like getting rid of the tag using
projects cleavage
or using our again film finish service
ali quoting the protein
so that is ready for your downstream
application
or even adjusting concentration if you
need
and so on
all right so
i think we have again a quick break here
you will now see a polling question
appear on your screen
your participation is greatly
appreciated
okay so i i'd like to spend the last few
minutes
to go even one step further and describe
you the possibility to go
not only from gene to protein but also
from gene to structure
so we know that a lot of researchers are
interested
in resolving the structure of the
protein and
x-ray crystallography is of course very
very powerful and has been improved in
the past years
but it there are still bottlenecks in
using these technologies if
one think of um crystallization of
membrane proteins or
large complexes like in the ribosome and
so forth so
for for these cases cryo-electron
microscopy
is is really um a valid option
and cryo-em is so fast that you can get
your protein structures
really in a few weeks instead of a few
months so if you start barely with an
electronic sequence you can get your dna
in two weeks using our service
then three additional weeks to do
transactional the cell line purification
and then finally you can use trioem if
you accessed this technology
to produce your protein structure and
we did a simple feasibility study using
protein p97 which is in rtpas
and used the workflow i was highlighting
before using
our gene optimization gene synthesis
protein purification
and then after freezing the protein
using basically bringing it
to cryoscopic temperature
uh what happened next is that in cryoam
electrons are fired at copies of frozen
molecules
and an electron deflection is recorded
by detectors
and with complex softwares
the images can be stitched together in
the
two-dimensional and then 3d classes and
this is really
an exciting process which is getting
better and better
and there is i think a recent
publication
uh pointing out that researchers were
able to use cryoam to get a resolution
of
1.25 angstroms which is just amazing
because it means that
we are now able to redefine the position
of individual atoms
so in our experiment we were able to
determine the structure of p97
also in presence of this substrate which
is atp
and you can imagine like for x-ray
crystallography to use this technique to
crystallize your protein in presence in
the presence of the relative substrate
or antagonist
or anything so i think this is an
exciting
further development of project protein
structure determination
and it's of course something we're
looking into to be
maybe able soon to offer to you a
infrastructure service
i've been talking in detail about gene
synthesis and protein synthesis services
and products from thermo fisher
scientific and i would like to mention
an additional advantage
over alternative providers which is our
customer
support network so we assist customers
through our customer care group
our technical safe specialists and our
global technical support
with more than 200 scientists located at
18 different sites around the globe
and now i'd like to wrap up
the t takeaways of this webinar are that
gene synthesis
is a cornerstone for synthetic biology
and enables to produce
genes from scratch giving access to any
sequence regardless its origin
or complexity gene optimization
is a complex process which is key to
obtain
successful gene expression in
heterogeneous
as a inauthologist host
constructing large dna is simple and
convenient
if you use general strings combined with
gener gibson assembly kit
and this is ideal to construct larger
genes or even entire pathways
and finally the recipe to obtain high
protein yield
is to combine geno gene optimization
technology
with advanced expression systems such as
xp 293 and xp cho which are the highest
starter systems
in the market
so if you want to partner with thermo
fisher to accelerate your research
you can reach out to us using
your local sales representative or visit
thermofisher.comart
and of course you can reach out to our
customer care team
by sending an email at genartsupport
thermofisher.com
and with this i'd like to thank you very
much for your attention and
i'm looking forward to taking your
questions
thank you claudia for your informative
presentation
we will now start the live q a portion
of the webinar
if you have a question you would like to
ask please do so now
just click on the ask a question box
located on the far left of your screen
we'll answer as many questions as we
have time for
our first question is what is the
longest gene you can synthesize
all right this is very much dependent on
complexity of the dna
so if you go for the standard gene
synthesis service
we are able to synthesize with no
problem dna up to 12 kb
but of course we are also able to
synthesize larger dna since we have a
special manufacturing team
here at the site which is really
dedicated to
the synthesis of more complex dna so if
you are interested in larger dna
you can just reach out to our customer
care team
and discuss with us the project and i'm
sure we can
we can provide you with a complex and
large dna as well
okay thank you claudia our second
question here is
how many different host systems can you
optimize for
okay gene optimizer can do
optimization for at least 200
different hosts what you will find in
our
portal and in the instant designer or
strengths assistant if you order in
general strings are the top
40 organisms which are selected normally
by
researchers for gene optimization again
if you don't find your ideal organisms
in this selection you can contact us and
i'm pretty sure we can satisfy your
request
when cloning strings how many colonies
do i need to pick
to find an error-free clone
this is dependent on the length of the
string
i would say so if you if you have a
string which is comprised
between 150 bits per and i would say
1.5 it's free enough to pick two clones
if you are doing screen for uh
strings up to 3kb is probably enough to
select four
clones so it is really simple
uh the screening process since we use
um uh an error correction mechanism
and an enzymatic error correction which
really reduce
the oligo errors um which are common
after gene synthesis
so that the pre screening s4f4 is really
very
reduced for you as a customer
okay our next question is do i need to
pick more colonies if my string lengths
are longer
yes i would recommend to go for
i would say four to maximum six colonies
if you have a 3kb a large string
and as i said our arrow correction
mechanism really improves
the correctness of the gene and it
reduce
extremely the the presence of errors in
the dna
so it is really safe to pick
46 colonies for large strings
okay thank you i've got another question
how do i know if i should build my dna
as a string or a clone
yes this is this is simple if you use
our
string general string assistant for
example
and this is something we've really been
improving in the past years because
at the beginning the customer was just
having the message
we are not able to synthesize your
sequence as a string
so now it really improved a lot because
we
we say why eventually we're not able to
synthesize it as a string
and we offer to you the chance to change
the sequence
often we have to do we open reading
frames so we can use
the degenerated code to of course
optimize the sequence for also for
making it less complex
and so what what you have to do is just
to agree to the changes
we we ask you to consider
and then the sequence can become a
legible and if it's still not
producible as a string then you will get
a message that we can synthesize this as
clone gene so you should just order it
as a standard gene synthesis
okay our next question is are there any
limitations to using my own vector for
cloning
actually no because you can request
sub-cloning in any vector you want
and this is just a simple additional
step of after gene synthesis
and the other possibility as i was
mentioning before
there are eligible customers we who
really
orders a lot of dna and or very
frequently
in the same construct and what we can do
is that we can modify this vector for
your
own use we can modify it in a way that
we adapt it to our manufacturing
procedure
and express cloning can be possible also
in your vector
if you like
okay thank you claudia it looks like we
have time for one more question
can i order a protein quantity as
opposed to a scale
this is possible it is possible but to
be sure we can deliver the amount of
protein you need we need to do a pilot
test
so we would do a quick pilot just to see
how much protein is normally produced
using our cell lines
and then of course you'll get informed
and if everything looks fine
then we can do the production of your
requested amount
thank you claudia thank you again for
your time today
and for your important research we would
also like to thank
lab roots and our sponsor thermo fisher
scientific
for underwriting today's educational
webcast
before we go i'd like to thank the
audience for joining us today
and for their interesting questions
questions we did not have time for today
and those submitted during the on-demand
period will be addressed by the speaker
via the contact information you provided
at the time of registration
this webcast can be viewed on demand lab
roots will alert you via email when it's
available for replay
we encourage you to share that email
with your colleagues who may have missed
today's live event
until next time goodbye